- And today is National Drink Wine day.
Obviously we have to celebrate that
'cause it would be rude not to.
And we thought what
better place to do that
in Southern California than Alfresco?
So let's head up there now.
Jason, could you give
the people some music
while I make my way to the roof?
(upbeat music)
Okay. Here we go.
I (indistinct) like this.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
Hey, what's up again?
So let's say hi to our first guest.
She is none other than
the marvelous Mrs. Maisel.
We love her. The show returns
to Amazon Prime Video today.
You gotta check it out, I love it.
There she is, Rachel Brosnahan, everybody.
What's up?
- Kelly, how are you?
- So we meet in person.
- Finally after about a...
Time doesn't fly so long.
- I don't know how long.
I feel like I've been in virtual,
like things forever.
- I am sure you do.
- Yeah, we literally started our show
and we haven't had a normal season yet,
so it's kind of normal, I guess.
- Yeah. New normal.
- But it's nice to see you in person.
- You too. Thank you.
- I will say I'm gonna lead this off
with literally when your show came out,
all my friends and family were like,
you need to watch this show.
They have depicted your
personality in a whole film.
So, and I was like, what?
(Rachel laughing)
And I watched it and I
was like, I was like,
"Okay, I'm not offended."
That's awesome, I love her.
- That's talking aloud,
- 'cause you're like,
should watch I it?
- But great fashion.
- Exactly. Exactly.
I love the show though. I
didn't know that it took...
You've been off for like two years.
Y'all haven't been shooting
for like two years.
- [Rachel] Yeah. Well it's-
- That's crazy. 'cause of COVID?
- It was a, there was
a panini, as I'd say.
- [Kelly] I know, but that's hard
to like jump back in character, right?
- [Rachel] Yeah, it was definitely,
we were a little bit slow
when we started back up,
I think that's the hardest part.
The show is a million miles an hour.
And I remember Tony Shalhoub saying
it made me laugh so hard.
First day back, of course they picked
the most complicated scene to shoot.
- Sure.
- All the children,
the entire cast,
and Tony would come off
between takes and he'd go,
"I think the words are
coming outta my mouth
but my brain is a full beat behind."
- Oh my God.
- He was like,
I'm just hoping, I'm hoping it's good.
I'm hoping it's here.
But yeah, it was so nice to come back.
- That's hard though.
That's like when artists
don't tour for a while
and then you get back
there and you're like,
I guess I'll go to this side
of the stage.
- You just like forget
how to use your body.
- Literally, you feel like
- That's me. You're like.
- [Kelly] Talladega nights. You're like,
I guess my hands, I don't know.
- What do I do with these meat sacks?
- Yeah, it's so weird.
Well, I don't know if you know this,
but today is National Drink Wine Day,
and who am I
- Just today?
- to frown upon a holiday?
- Yeah, exactly. (laughing)
- Just one day.
- [Kelly] It's a day that ends in wine.
- Great.
- So I thought we'd celebrate.
Are you in to, are you into wine?
Are you into...
- Do I like air? Do I need air to, yes.
- Okay, well we have a
lovely Goldeneye Brut Rose.
- Ooh.
- Goldeneye is part of the decor portfolio
which is nothing less than the go-to wine
for the Kelly Clarkson show.
That's what I'm saying.
Would you like to toast?
- [Rachel] Cheers.
- [Kelly] I don't know if
we're allowed, but we did it.
Oh my God.
- Oh, we didn't drink it yet.
- What should we drink too?
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel?
- Sure, and to you.
- [Kelly] You're back.
- And to the new normal of your show.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. In
2022, let's have a better-
- 2022.
- Come on Jesus.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
Come on Jesus, take the wheel.
So we've also got fries and sliders
because I'm all about a little
class and a little trash.
- [Rachel] Me too, love it.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah. The high-low.
If you could choose a last meal,
what would your last meal be?
- I'm, I'm-
- This is hard.
- I think it would be this.
- Really?
- I'm not kidding.
It would be like a good
old fashion smashburger
and fries with all this stuff.
- Maybe some truffle on it?
- This is is my dream.
- [Kelly] Okay, yes.
- What about you?
- I go back and forth, but I don't know.
I think I'm just gonna ask
for chips and queso and salsa.
(Kelly laughs)
- Really?
- [Kelly] I'm not gonna
ask for a full meal.
- Guac?
- I like guac but not as much
as I like queso and salsa,
and I'm talking like Tex-Mex queso.
- Amazing.
- [Kelly] Not that weird melted thing
that people do out here,
but I heard that you
enjoy something called
- The shade.
Throwing right now.
I heard that you enjoy
something called shower wine?
What is this?
- It's wine one drinks in the shower.
(Kelly laughs)
It's a good old fashioned shower.
- [Kelly] I like bath wine.
- [Rachel] Yeah, great.
- [Kelly] Oh my God,
you're full on in a shower
just like yeah.
- Yeah, you have a hard day.
- I'm gonna try this.
- It's a way to have,
it's a way to have it all.
It's a way to have all
the things all at once.
You have a nice warm shower.
You put on some tunes,
just bring your glass in with you
so that you can have all
the relaxation at once.
- 'Cause it's such a great
thing. People forget,
a shower is amazing.
I don't know if you've ever been camping,
but I was camping for a minute one time
and we didn't shower for a while.
And I was like, oh, I like the steam.
- It's all over your body.
All at the same time.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Love a bath too. But you
know yeah, exactly the steam.
- [Kelly] Wine in the shower.
- Yeah. Shower wine.
- [Kelly] I like your style.
- Yeah.
- Little table for it
in there. Okay, okay.
Do you have any other?
- Especially, yeah.
If you have like a little,
I don't know, you can put it on anything,
a turned over planter
or if you have a bench
or just on the floor.
- Because you're like,
that plant died. (laughs)
- [Rachel] Yeah, exactly.
- I couldn't properly take
care of that. (laughs)
- [Rachel] I couldn't keep that alive.
So it's my shower wine stand now.
- [Kelly] I love it. It's
totally happened to me.
I try and keep them alive.
But do you have any
other beverage fixations?
Because I'm obsessed with coffee and tea.
- [Rachel] Just general.
All coffee and tea?
- I love the ritual of it.
I love all of it.
- What kind of tea? What kind of coffee?
- All kinds.
Like I will do decaf,
it depends on the type of day.
I love tea.
Like I have my only thing that steeps it
for the amount of time.
Like I love caffeine,
I love herbal, I love everything.
- [Rachel] So you like the ritual?
Is there like a time of day that you...
- Any time of day.
- [Rachel] Any time, any where.
- Yeah. It's probably why I'm like
(funny noise)
- All coffee,
all the time.
- All the time.
It's probably what they
I'm your character.
(both laughing)
- It takes a lot of coffee.
- A lot.
- No tea.
Only coffee to keep that one going.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love both. Do you?
- I do. And I also,
this is a very unpopular opinion,
so I'm trying not to get canceled
on Kelly Clarkson this morning
but I love gas station coffee.
I think it's a...
- Like on a road trip?
Like if it's your option,
that's the option?
- [Rachel] Like always.
- Like that's your pick?
- [Rachel] I mean, that's not
where I would go every day.
But I do love, I think
it's a nostalgic thing.
You said camping.
I grew up camping a lot
and you know, you're out in the woods
and there's nothing
better than instant coffee
in the morning.
- Oh my gosh.
- You pour it in. It wakes you up.
You're out in nature and it feels so good.
- It's warm.
- I think it's a remnant of that.
It's like when you entered civilization,
there was always a gas
station or when you feel like-
- They always have all the fixings too.
- [Rachel] Yeah. Getting of the plane.
- Like if you want some creamer.
- Coffee-mate.
- Yeah.
- Most basic thing about me.
(Kelly laughing)
Love vanilla Coffee-mate.
- [Kelly] Most basic thing about me.
It's awesome.
- [Rachel] Yeah. Vanilla Coffee-mate.
- I love that.
- Gas station coffee.
- [Kelly] Catch you at a Seven-Eleven
just throwing down on some caffeine.
- That's right.
- [Kelly] So we just showed
you a clip of her show,
The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel.
So is it true that the show has given you
Mrs. Maisel nightmares?
Is this real?
- [Rachel] Absolutely.
- What kind of nightmares?
- Well, if you've seen this show,
as you know, it's a lot of dialogue.
It's a lot of fast talking.
We have these, excuse me, can I go ahead?
- [Kelly] Yeah. I'm not gonna stop you.
- [Rachel] It's National Drink Wine Day.
- Yeah. It's rude to make me drink alone.
- [Rachel] That's right.
(Kelly laughs)
We have a ton of dialogue,
we don't always have a lot
of time to memorize it.
And so I find that if I fall,
if I learn lines too late at night
or I do that terrible
thing where you fall asleep
with the script on your
chest, just like, you know.
Then I start running lines in my dreams.
And so I start having stress dreams.
It's like, I'll wake up and I'm,
I wake up in my dream and I'm on stage
and I'm delivering these lines
and I forget one, you know,
it's like that naked in
front of an audience.
- I've done that on
stage in musical theater.
- But my teeth fall out in my dream.
- [Kelly] Oh, a loss of control
is what I hear that that is.
- [Rachel] I've never heard
that. It's just anxiety.
- [Kelly] Oh, and that would be it.
That would cause me anxiety.
- I've been talking really fast
and doing all these jokes
and then suddenly I'm like,
(beep) and all my teeth are falling.
- [Kelly] I've heard my
teeth falling out means
that you have a loss of
control or something.
- [Rachel] That checks out.
- But you know, that tracks.
- That tracks. (laughing)
- [Kelly] That's terrifying
though to memorize all the,
I'm so bad at memorizing stuff.
- Are you?
- I'm horrible.
Horrible, I have to have a teleprompter.
I'm horrible.
- What do you do for your songs?
- Teleprompter. I learned
that from Steven Tyler.
I literally met him like
early on in my career,
and I would stress out
and I literally would change the lyrics
to every song 'cause I'd just freak out.
Especially the ones I wrote.
- I like that though.
- 'Cause I didn't remember
what I ended with.
- And nobody knows right?
- I have the worst memory.
Yes. So I have,
and here's the thing you don't
often look at it generally,
but you have it there
and for some reason
that insurance makes me,
yeah, I have the worst memory.
- [Rachel] That's the scariest thing about
like live theater, about musical theater.
- [Kelly] I did musical theater
and I like freaking mess up every line,
like I mess up all the time.
I have to improv.
Do y'all improv, are you not allowed?
- No. We are word perfect to,
and I think that's part of it is that
you wanna get it right because it does,
it's like musical,
it's musical in a way.
It sounds the best when you hit the music.
So if you drop a word, the
music doesn't sound right.
And so it is stressful.
But it comes out in the dreams
and then I wake up in the morning
and I'm super sleepy and
I'm like, here we go.
(Kelly laughs)
Hope my teeth don't fall out today.
- Oh my God, that's stressful.
Wait, did it get any
easier in season four?
You're used to kind of the dialogue?
Well, you took two years off, maybe not.
- No, and it didn't get any easier,
but that's kind of the dream.
It's equally as terrifying
every single time.
And that's because it's never the same.
It's something new every time.
In season one, Midge wasn't a comedian.
She was a funny woman
having a mental breakdown,
having a prolonged mental breakdown.
- Which dark comedy.
- [Rachel] Yeah, in a very funny way.
And then as the show went on,
she began to kind of find her voice
and own and learn how to do jokes
that might appeal to a wider audience.
And I think what you'll
see in this new season
is her digging into what she
believes her superpower is.
And not trying to craft her art
around what the expectation of her is
or what would please other people.
She's digging her heels in
for better and for worse.
But it just means that everything is new.
There's some new styles of
comedy we tried this year,
that were absolutely petrifying
but we did it, we made it through.
- I was terrified.
I had nightmares.
- Yeah, every minute.
- Well, do you feel
like if you're playing,
like if you're playing a comedian,
do you feel like you're
getting funnier in real life?
- Absolutely not.
- [Kelly] No, really?
- Nope. I feel like,
- [Kelly] Like picking
up some of their timing?
- No, I wish. I wish it worked like that.
I wish I absorbed it by osmosis,
but I feel like it's,
it's more that now I have a
better idea of what funny is.
So I know really clearly
where and when I'm missing the mark.
(both laughing)
I can hear it in real time.
Like when we started the show,
Alex Borstein said to me,
and I'll never forget it.
She was like, thank God,
you're not a comedian
because then you'd be able to hear
when people aren't laughing.
And I couldn't tell,
couldn't tell the difference
between when they were saying, okay,
(mouthing laugh)
- [Kelly] Oh.
- You know, and I was like,
wow, this is going so
well for me, you know.
- I'm amazing.
- [Rachel] But now I
can tell the difference.
- I love it.
- And it's both scary when
it doesn't quite work,
but it feels great when you
do suddenly hit something
that you didn't know you could do.
- Also, if it doesn't work,
blame the writers.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Rachel] Sure, yeah.
But I also am like,
- [Kelly] It's not my words.
- I'm just gonna leave
the comedy to the writers.
I'm gonna stop trying
to do this on my own.
- [Kelly] That's what's so great
about you love the writers so much
that you stick to the
script, like so closely.
- [Rachel] Absolutely. They're brilliant.
And I should never,
everyone's always like,
do you have a go-to joke?
And you know, I had to come up with.
- Do you?
- [Rachel] Well, yes.
- [Kelly] That means yes.
- I have one.
- [Kelly] Oh, that means
it's inappropriate.
- But it's a fresh audience.
- I love it.
- Okay.
- Okay. I'm gonna give it to you.
Audience, listen. I'm not
a comedian all on my own.
Okay, so what is the difference
between a tire and 365 condoms?
I almost forgot.
- Well, they're both rubber. (laughing)
- That's a different kind of,
- I don't know.
I don't know.
- Are you looking at me...?
- No, what's the difference?
- One is a good year
and one is a great year.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
I'll be here for the next 25 minutes.
- [Kelly] I'm totally stealing that.
I love that.
I was like, where is this going?
They're both made of rubber.
I was like trying to guess it.
- Well, it's a good year one.
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
- Thank you.
- And you're welcome,
you had gear for that.
- And that was the beginning
and the end of my comedy.
- I know, I love it.